تفاعل كبير مع الصور كريم بنزيما على
مواقع التواصل
الجزائري بن رحمه يحتفل بطريقه خاصه بعد
تتويج فريقه
و ريال مدريد ينسحب من صفقه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد وصول كريب بنزيما الى مدينه جده
للانضمام الى فريق الاتحاد تواصلوا صوره
تسجيل ارقام لافته في التفاعل على موقع
انستجرام حيث تجاوزت الاعجابات بصوره
التوقيع عقده مع نادي الاتحاد 4 ملايين
الف لايك بينما حظي الفيديو الترويجي
للصفقه باكثر من 24 مليون مشاهده هذا هو
سيتم تقديم البنس في ملعب الجوهره مساء
اليوم امام نحو 62 الف مشجع
توج النجم الجزائري سعيد بن رحمه باول لقب
اوروبي له مع نادي بعد الفوزى امام
فيونتنا الايطالي في نهائي دوري المؤتمر
الجماهير الجزائريه تفعلت بقوه على منصات
السوشيال ميديا مع من رحمه الذي اطلق بثا
مباشرا على فيسبوك وهو ينقص الانغامي
موسيقى الراي رفقه زملائه الاخرين في
الفريق
في الجهه المقابله يواصل الحظ معاهده
الانديه الايطاليه في النهائيات الاوروبيه
فبعد وصولي ثلاثه فرق من ايطاليا الى
المباريات النهائيه للمسابقات القاريه هذا
الموسم فشل ناديا روما وفيورنتينا
بلقبي الدوري الاوروبي ودور المؤتمر فيما
تبدو مهمته انتر هي الاصعب عندما يواجهوا
بطل انجلترا هذه مانشستر سيتي والذي
يستهدف التتويج بالثلاثيه التاريخيه رفقه
مدربه جوسيب غوارديولا
يبدو انها لن يكتب له مغادره توتنهام
بعدما سحب ريال مدريد عرضه للاعب والسبب
هو المطالب الماديه المبالغ فيها لتوتنهام
بحسب نادي الاسباني ويطلب ليبيا رئيس
سبيرز نحو 120 مليون يورو لانتقال كينج
كما طلبه وكلاء اللاعب راتبا يتجاوز 20
مليون يورو سنويا لقائد منتخب انجلترا
رئيس ريال مدريد ان هذه الارقام لا تناسب
الصفقه خاصه وان هاري كين يبلغ من العمر
29 عاما
[موسيقى]